tout de suite avec notre reporter bassem
chebil et à tunis bonjour bassem alors
c'est un week-end tendue que les
tunisiens ont vécu comment se sont
déroulées les mouvements de protestation
bonjour j écoutais encore un week end
assez tendue et mouvementée d'un point
de vue manifestations et d'un point de
vue engagement de la population ce sont
des mouvements qui ont commencé comme
vous savez à partir du 14 janvier c'est
à la date anniversaire des dix ans de la
révolution
il ya eu pas mal de violences nocturnes
dans les quartiers populaires que ce
soit johnny ce sur l'ensemble du
territoire tunisien et puis ces
manifestations et qui a commencé il ya
maintenant trois semaines de cela et ça
commence à devenir progressivement une
tradition malgré le fait que l'on ne
cuit ont de plus de faire appel à la
population via les réseaux sociaux car
la police traque d'une personne qui
appelle à manifester
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
des mouvements de manifestations
s'intensifient car il regrette qu un des
seuls acquis de la révolution à savoir
cette liberté d'expression soit
complètement bafouée et le volet par la
police une police qui est accusé de
faire preuve de violence durant ces
manifestations des slogans hostiles
toujours au gouvernement qui est qui qui
est complètement fragilisé en ce moment
de la crise sanitaire on assiste à une
crise politique au sein même du
parlement
et puis les entre le parlement et le
gouvernement et bien sûr les pointer du
doigt le parti islamiste ennahda courant
responsables du chaos économique et
sanitaire auquel le pays se trouve
actuellement c'étaient les jeunes qui
sont en première ligne de ces
manifestations comptait plus d'un
millier de personnes à cette
manifestation
ces jeunes qui sont bien déterminés à
descendre la rue de continuer tes
cendres pour réclamer leurs acquis de la
révolution je vous propose d'écouter
quelques réactions que j'ai pu
recueillir lors de cette manifestation
samedi date c'est la continuité de la
série d'une série des manifs contre
les agressions policières quand on a
vécu tout au long du mois de janvier
si dix ans ont fait la révolution on ait
affronté une politique aussi polisseur
est aussi agressif que ça on n'a rien
fait en fait aujourd'hui il y à tous les
jeunes tout le peuple a constaté qu'il
ya un retour en arrière sur la seule
chose qu'on a gagné de la révolution qui
est la liberté d'expression à la liberté
de se manifester
aujourd'hui le peuple doit prendre en
main les choses et doit récupérer sa
révolution volée est bon de profiteurs
qui veulent une chose une seule chose
c'est rester au pouvoir
quel que soit le prix voilà l'été des
milliers samedi dernier c'était une
nouvelle par rapport à une première
monte par rapport aux autres
manifestations qu'on a pu vivre
simplement parce que le gtt si l'union
générale syndicale des travailleurs
tunisiens de syndicats puissants du pays
avait demandé aussi à descendre dans la
rue pour fêter les habitants de
l'assassinât de chokri belaïd qui était
un militant complètement engagé contre
le gouvernement militants est laïque la
zone pour laquelle beaucoup de personnes
avaient fait le déplacement samedi
dernier pour ces manifestations alors
bassam vous le disiez il s'agit ans mère
d'une crise des institutions en tunisie
le président kaïs à yale ce qu'il peut
trouver une issue petit fruit ni sur
l'équipe gouvernementale c'est un peu
compliqué parce que depuis quelques
semaines d'un remaniement ministériel
qui est proposé le premier ministre mais
chichi les uns pas calmé les tensions
c'était le but de ce remaniement et ça
fait et défait intéresse tout simplement
car le président d'al public a vécu ça
comme une sorte de trahison lui qui
avait placé mes fichiers à ce poste de
premier ministre
il devait reformer son gouvernement avec
de nouvelles nominations et dans ses
onze nominations
beaucoup d'entre elles ne satisfont pas
le peuple mais surtout le président de
la république à nous qualifier certaines
de ces mines et de ses airs de ces
nominations comme une supercherie car
certains ministres sont accusés de
corruption
des choix qui ont été nettement orientés
par le parti islamiste ennahda on accuse
de vichy bien sûr de faire le jeu du
parti
l'islamiste le président de la
république a même reconnu qu'il ne
reconnaîtrait pas cette résidence et ce
ministre là d'autres éléments aussi qui
font que la situation est assez critique
le présent la république a même pointé
du doigt le fait que ces nominations ne
sont pas passés en délibération concédé
mise comme le suggère la constitution le
président trouve ces nominations
anticonstitutionnel je vous propose
d'écouter un extrait de cette
déclaration du président wade
nous sommes prêts pour toutes les
éventualités
mais jamais je ne céderai sur mes
principes je suis prêt au dialogue mais
je ne suis pas prêt à dialoguer avec
ceux qui ont volé le peuple tunisien
comme l'a souligné le président de la
république et beaucoup de personnes de
la société civile se piqua remaniement
ministériel complètement
contre-productif et ont raison d'une
situation de crise dans la mesure où
beaucoup de postes clés comme le
ministère de la justice ministère de
l'intérieur l'encore ou encore la santé
elle est vacant malgré cette remaniement
ministériel le président la république
bien sûr n'a pas souhaité recevoir ces
nouveaux ministres pour qu'ils puissent
se prêter un serment donc on est
tellement dans une situation très
instable d'un point de vue politique
encore pire d'un point de vue économique
et sanitaire
il faut s'attendre bien sûr à de
nouveaux mouvements sociaux dans les
jours à venir et samedi prochain et on
attend bien sûr une sorte de rééquilibre
sein du parlement et une fibre de
confiance entre le premier ministre et
le président de la république pour
contre l'abus se stabiliser et de la
sphère politique en tunisie
merci beaucoup bassem pour toutes ces
précisions bassem chab y vous étiez en
direct de tunis